foreign
[Music]
with nerd content Amazon has perfected
their own take on the genre blood
and speed
see this is what rings of power was
missing
you saw me there
you but
the boys
Seasons two and three
join back up with the all books
government murder Squad known as the
boys
they're the good guys Huey is still
doing the will they won't they they did
who cares thing with Starlight while he
crafts a new Alter Ego as Captain Save A
Hoe let me save you for once I can
finally save you for once I saved you
Annie all I want is to save you butcher
is still finding fun new ways to lose
friends and alienate people
but who will come to learn is secretly a
father with the heart of gold and it's
gone maybe I don't want to look at you
and tagging along are the other ones
Frenchy mother's milk and Kimiko who
hang out in the background doing drugs
until we can all get back to the fun
part friendship you high well that goes
without saying
they're here to take down homelander a
terrifying combo of Zack Snyder's
Superman and Zack Snyder's Superman fans
I'm better
I am better as he shows off his awesome
powers of comparing himself to damn near
anybody Dr Martin Luther King he was
persecuted spoke truth to power just
like me the mountain to Muhammad as it
were I know exactly how he must have
felt Jesus and the scariest set of
on-screen Jaws since the shark movie
[Music]
thank you
soar back to season two when the writers
thought hmm maybe we were being too
subtle and put a literal Nazi on the
show
he was a lovely dancer and that's
goebbles enter storm front this rule 34
Hitler has terrifying powers like
lightning
racism he is pretty smart especially for
his kind and being a woman in her 80s
who can actually use social media when
you see it on your uncle's Facebook page
then you know it's working
how
raid-based evil will combine with CEO
Stan Edgars more numbers based evil it's
not fruitless it's prices per share
that's all as Giancarlo Esposito's
master plan nears its completion play
every calculating schemer on television
and animation and video games
of the stakes for season three when the
writer said hmm are we still being too
subtle and whipped out the Star-Spangled
featuring Hero guys um an episode about
a super orgy that's the least sexy part
of a show where the Deep humps an
octopus that poop shoots had a workout
huh looks like the Lincoln Tunnel the
reveal of black no war as this regular
black guy hmm no spoilers but not quite
the same effect as the comic reveal I
did like his Happy Tree Friends though
we are so proud of you and a whole orb
devoted to newcomer and old Comer
soldier boy he may have been winter
soldiered in a Russian prison for
decades but when the boys bust him out
we'll meet Captain actual America hands
off the [__] Shield he's yet another
a-hole on a show that's full of them but
he's the only chance we've got to take
down homelander unless anyone's got a
cell phone handy You're Gonna Leave Me
and Elena alone or I release this I'm in
the seven wonderful what you're not
supposed to record us when we're running
lines get rid of it now
dive into the character's emotional
backstories to learn what drives their
dysfunction Huey finally gets over his
daddy issues he wasn't weak
didn't know what strength was while his
boss Victoria must deal with her daddy
issues you're not his daughter you're
his weapon and butcher must confront his
daddy issues
while mother's milk confronts his daddy
issues you can close the book on him
once and for all for your dad and when
she confronts his daddy issues before
William butcher it was me
for me it was your daddy as soldier boy
confronts his daddy issues said it was a
disappointment
not good enough to carry his name while
homelander Works through his mommy
issues
by replacing them with brand new daddy
issues just we're all on the same page
here did you know that I had a father
out there alive this whole time
so suit up for the show that's a little
too smart for juvenile edged Lords but a
little too dumb and gross to recommend
to anyone without internet brain
poisoning get to the prostate in this
universe that's become the very thing it
seems to hate a successful superhero
franchise beloved by all made possible
by an evil Corporation
[Laughter]
foreign
The Flash urban legend meme Lander
[Applause]
Soldier Boy Kill Em that boy ain't right
The Lumineers Leon the unprofessional
the strong silent type Thor Chan Call Me
Maybe track live splatter the dark
knight dark Arc Gus fringe science
Newman
and Disney's 2023 PR team
[Music]
War for the planet of the caves
yeah this show is good but the Japanese
dub is way better
homelander butcher storm fraud there's
no shortage of major jerks on this show
so we put them head to head in a jerk
off or evil off in an all-new episode of
by the Numbers click the Box on the
right to see who wins
you me a king-sized bed and a bucket of
glitter any questions help me help you
help me help you
would you like a tofu flavored KitKat